we got our third show on sale right now
at The Gramercy theater let's go the
army of garbage came correct in New York
City sold out two shows we added our
third links in the description let's
party baby Friday February 3rd we'll see
you there see you there welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that they grow up to be
classy yes they're just a big old piece
of trash I'm real estate's fully coming
that show on a beautiful day we're down
here at Antilles basement she's upstairs
thank God cleaning the place up okay I'm
tripping over catalytic converters up
there okay for God's sake my co-host is
coming at you from across the table
that's what we call a good old-fashioned
Family episode Circle in the wagons he
is the CEO of Ru garbage my best pal and
I'll tell you this not a bad looking kid
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan it's
the first time he ever said that what's
up everybody thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
it's cooking it's a good time closing on
110k over there and obviously the
greatest gosh darn tooting website I'd
have ever seen www.patreon.com
garbage check it out gang we got bonus
episodes over there we got episodes of
hard feelings The Runaway hit of 2023.
I've heard episodes of hard feelings uh
we got a bunch of bonus content on there
we got us on the road we've been flying
new guy Luke around the country with us
Wheels shooting Vlog wheels up is the
Vlog we got a new one dropping soon
breakfast with the boys let's practice
for everybody in Rhode Island oh not too
bad with the cheesy eggs I'll tell you
that this kid yeah it's a good time over
there on that patreon I love it you love
it
sir I think you swallowed your tongue
finally or they were jumped out finally
made a run sinus season what do you want
gang how about a nice quick shout out to
our producers gang how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the Magic Band makes us
all look good works those ones and twos
crosses them T's and dots them eyes give
it up for Toby McMullen everybody hey
what's up what's up T-Bone you got a big
man hit me with a nickname season
apparently yeah really Jam you up it's
hard to get mcgruffins out sounds like a
it sounds like a hunting season you know
with Sonic season right you only want to
keep two
I gotta sinus mount on the hood of my
car
Skittle season duck season
I saw a bunch of deer streaming across
the road uh up there at Fort Washington
so I was getting back on the turnpike
they're getting real I was down there on
boxes while I was down outside the Old
Philadelphia area they're getting dude
that we got foxes here we got Fox too
never seen them two foxes just walking
through my backyard babes
I lower my glasses
I ain't talking about a couple of birds
that go to the beauty school either
a couple of times
shake off the heat
yikes just two girls in those old thong
bikinis the hot like the [ __ ] golden
arch the old headphones on with like the
orange I got the high socks up they're
doing aerobics what you looking at well
I'm gonna get an Orange Julius hit you
with that hey baldy quit staring
yeah like you got a shot hey you want
one of those whatever I have my um
I've mentioned her before uh I might
have said the fox That Got Away
Trisha I used to love you okay it's good
now our talk about The Fox and the Hound
come on
also too this came up uh a couple days
ago I was talking to somebody
um
something came up uh uh when someone
says they're a hound dog but he's a real
hound dog who says what were you talking
to a gumshoe who says that guy's a real
hound dog
no one's ever said that really
except for Elvis yeah and he wasn't even
a hound dog that was like but he was
nothing but a house when they when they
have a taste for the ladies he's a bit
of a hound dog I don't know I was
talking to a buddy of mine about one of
his older kids okay one of his older
kids and he's a bit of a hound dog kid's
a bit of a hound dog poonhound those we
call it why not back when I was banging
a little bit you guys are real he
uncovered some evidence that you know
he's like he's like he's getting to that
age now okay he's like hey he's got a
little hound dog in him
that was pretty good yeah that's all
right hey see there you go ridiculed me
anyway
um the way the deer went across the road
I couldn't see them and they my dad
always put the fear of God into me about
those things basically I feel like if
one of those things hit your car it's
gonna explode like a like a drone strike
and I'm petrified of them but would
never want to hurt them so whenever I
see them on the side eating like a
little grass or something I beat the
horn and slow down hit the lights but
that though you can't do the lights it's
scary you freezes them and then they get
real wire to get that look I had the
same thing I was driving home the other
night they're real nervous they start
shooting quick oh man they jumped the
wrong way they end up in the back seat
[ __ ] asking to ask him for the aux
cord
ask you to put on some Drizzy Drake make
a left on Cherry Street fat boy I got a
couple go with them snacks I got a
couple of foxes over there waiting on
them because I'm a real hound dog
um yeah no you get you gotta get I've
had them jump into the side of cars well
guy in my neighborhood and jump through
his front window like the bay window and
it causes a Ruckus at the house yeah we
had one jump in our school
too
gym teacher just put on a pair of
glasses
Everybody follow everybody started
listening to you see a deer around here
now pass me more berries please
um yeah one just drinking a little cup
of coffee oh yeah a little short sleeve
shirt a little time yeah I pictured like
the Dilbert he's rocking the door 100
talking about he's walking on his hind
legs down the hallway
you kids get to class that's Mr Jenkins
he's new here just [ __ ] behind him
um
one busted through our busted through a
window in our school and ran around
terrorized the school for a couple hours
and that's a that's a story they came
and got him that's just who the
government no the the the cops yeah he's
still serving a nickel
how do you handcuff a deer cut him in
the girl's locker room yes oh hound dog
no I am a Hound deer in them
um
Jack what are you gonna say that's
saying no you're trash if a deer's ever
run through your school yeah but you
can't lose [ __ ] coming from I knew it
then coming from those towns like not
this that
that's focal this is the story I told
you about the guy who jumped through his
window that was about 48 years ago and
that's still that's to watch out they
jumped through the Robertson's window
you know what I mean you gotta those
those stories live on forever because
not a lot happens down there now I
remember when I was a small town when I
was a kid they used bourbon towns when I
was a kid they used to say if you got a
spotlight like one of those huge
spotlights and you drove out into the
woods at night and you spotlighted
around if they catch if they catch it in
their eyes they freeze yeah like that's
insane a deer in the headlights oh yeah
it does that's why when they're running
across the street they catch it they
stopping you oh man uh-huh yikes anyway
um I didn't hit anything oh thank God
yeah
um
if anybody asks I was home with you all
night laughs
that story froze like a deer in a
headlights
I know I've been uh back and forth
between here and uh Denise's house the
past couple uh you know last week or so
um
tending to some family things and uh
I had the I've the past two days I've
had to use my wife's toothbrush
and I I dude I'd rather put on a grown
man's underwear that he just had on it's
it irks me wait really what I just
really rather have the underwear I don't
know that's crazy it's yeah but it's
like that Seinfeld thing it's a
subatomic level things are happening my
wife that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you kiss her yeah all right well
what's the difference
there is a difference there's a there's
a difference T-Bone we just recently
talked about this yeah you kiss it and
it will be the the equivalent isn't
kissing it would be like rubbing teeth
yeah which I don't mind by the way if
I've had enough drinks in me
because I use if it's my birthday sure I
used my girls by accident I'm sure she's
thrilled about that well no I gotta I
got her a new one and the only thing
that that pulls out of your mouth it's
melted
I felt bad for her you know what I mean
I feel like so you understand that there
is a difference there you feel bad for
her but I didn't feel bad I I understand
I didn't care about using hers I felt
bad that she would have to use it after
me I understand I'm the disgusting one
but there's I understand but there's
that still that if it's just like you
got skeeved out by using hers anybody's
it's the thing yeah it's just your girl
it was also wet when I started that's a
tough one like she had used it and then
I had she had just brushed her teeth
yeah huh
I had to do it this morning too man it
was tough I'd rather use hans's you need
money for one of those Greenies or
something I've been moving around a lot
I've been we've been leaving them by a
CVS huh I didn't realize it's always
that thing you know I always forget I'm
sure you stop somewhere for a sandwich
you could have stopped and got yourself
delivered what's [ __ ] Colgate starts
delivering and call me dude you get a
toothbroken toothbrush here in 10
minutes
please start that clock right now really
a toothbrush in 10 minutes you want me
to do it can you may I could if I wanted
in 10 minutes
and within the normal time I understand
seamlessly I understand I understand
seeing first of all seamless doesn't
deliver toothbrushes yeah they do from
where 7-Eleven they'll get you one oh
Uber eating survivors or whatever yeah
right hold on you're missing the point
the point is I only think I always only
think of toothpaste when I'm about to
brush my teeth that's why I always get
jammed up I run out of toothpaste and it
takes me like three days to be like [ __ ]
I keep forgetting I keep forgetting
because that's not a problem when I'm
out of the store of like oh yeah I need
a toothbrush if I could solve that could
have been solved that I wouldn't be in
this position it could always sneak
through the door one more time with the
toothpaste oh that's I know there's
always always
then you're hemmed up you got that
little [ __ ] prairie dog jumping out
here like it's giving it all your yeah
you stick the bristles in the hole Yeah
do a little digging in there trying to
get in there I still don't get why
you're skied that using your wife's
toothbrush anybody's toothbrush you
remove the relationship it's anybody's
toothbrush it's just it's a device used
to clean bacteria that you're then
putting you don't think that's bonding
in a way that's bonding in a way or what
about I'm not saying it does you
remember again remove the relationship
what about what about what about when
but you hold on when your parents you've
understood the parents you get disgusted
for your wife or your girlfriend but I'm
disgusting I know but she's not
disgusting just stop for a second and
understand if the relationship works
that way
then there is something to be disgusted
about
you your your threshold for disgusting
is just way higher than most peoples
my threshold for disgusting no
she's your wife's attracted that doesn't
have to do with anything in my head it
does yeah if it's an attractive person
I'm okay with it okay if they're gross
like me that's I felt bad for my girl
sure that she would have to use it after
me I had no problem using hers I rub it
in my face sticking up my butt sure to
me you're missing the point of if it's
disgusting for one person regardless of
how disgusting you are it's a tool used
to clean a witch on record very
um I would say most people let's do it
we're ready to do a poll leave it in the
con most people that's something they
don't want not their significant other
though I'm telling you it probably is
the case I don't know buddy you
understand it for your girlfriend how do
you not see that it works one way
because I'm disgusting I understand that
but I would feel most people and you're
nothing to write home about either of
course and she's an attractive lady what
looks doesn't have anything to do with
it it does bone structure has nothing to
do with bacteria in your mouth
I think it does and what to please
please relate that science because
you're attracted to her if you're
attracted to her what are you that
should should almost turn you on a
little bit okay I think your Rod's in
[ __ ] you're you're you're you're why
you're a little miswired somewhere I
don't know maybe call me a crazy kid I
don't know I guess I do see what you're
saying
yeah but also at the same time I feel
like you gotta understand where your
threshold for disgust you have boogers
on you all the time if it was my
toothbrush that you used I would
completely understand that anywho this
is a goddamn Family episode where we
answer your questions on patreon gang
when you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on air it's
just the best way to do it we get a
bunch of emails gmails emails the whole
nine yards but this is the best way to
do it let's go you ready big Feller hit
me cue ball strap in what do you got
this is from Royal lab tv never had one
red is it garbage to have a fisheye
mirror instead of an actual side view
mirror due to an alleged hit and run
this guy's got a fish eye as a rear view
mirror that cannot be safe for emerging
on highways on the left
I don't know a side view mirror okay I
have the same information you have a
side view a rear view mirror the side
view mirrors right you know how on on
Mac trucks they'll have like the
circular one yeah it's got the little
Banger yeah that's all he has I'm
assuming
[Music]
so he probably taped that onto his thing
when his mirror got knocked off bam I
don't know those are pretty good though
they really cover you I've driven not as
a primary use I don't know I've driven
in trucks that have them man I know but
you also have to check your regular six
that's like driving around looking
through people yeah that's not see their
future with those things it's like being
on the water it's still like eight miles
back
everything looks like a skate video
that's a very unsafe and tragedy to not
have a regular that doesn't pass
inspection sure I'll give you that yeah
that's I would argue highly dangerous
yeah
um buddy get it fixed or at least put
some tin foil I know people that have
these huge rear view mirrors yeah that
it looks weird but damn man you [ __ ]
you got everything yeah
um you know what's going on in the
streets with that thing you can see
around the corner with those bad boys
they're all right
um I we've rented some cars some newer
cars like the SUVs that have the video
as the rear view mirror rather than the
actual mirror which throws me because
I'm used to looking in the mirror and
seeing T-Bone back there and then you
don't see anything you just see the the
footage I'm back there unsupervised it
really [ __ ] you up I thought I was in
an empty oh the camera's not there no
they can't of course no the camera's on
the back see what these punks are doing
back oh you can't you're Flying Blind
somebody coming up with the [ __ ]
piano wire behind you and you don't know
[ __ ] dude nothing scarier as a kid than
your dad hitting the rear view just to
hit you oh turning that to make that eye
contact Jam you up toot sweet melt your
eyebrows off
because you know what but in my in my
family car you know what followed that
was a [ __ ] in inner thigh bite he'd
come around right oh no a pinch [ __ ]
come around can you do it [ __ ] catch
you right in the sense of the part of
your chubby thigh H and I jump up and
hold his eyes closer hey hey you want me
to go we all go I play chess not
Checkers over here boxes ears like
Beethoven wanna play games old man give
them vertigo real quick I'll take the
whole [ __ ] bloodline off the map
let's go pull a Jason board real quick
that choking your dad with a seatbelt
there was nothing you know what a
magazine
they have that they have some uh
competition where you fight in the front
seat that's good oh I think I've seen
that that's Russian MMA in a car that's
all right good times too oh man and they
can't fall because they just keep like
the guy's just knocked out just [ __ ]
there was nothing worse you could do
than hit that light on the inside of the
car when your parents were driving oh
yeah yeah they made it seem like the
highway was gonna blow up uh-huh yeah it
was bad look out hit that thing you're
dead cops will get you yeah what are you
[ __ ] doing I'm driving wild
um all right let's see this one's from
JB Henry long time listener never had
one read you or anyone you know that has
their litter box on carpet floor
I mean I'm not a cat guy but that can't
be good
dude cat I don't know how you just do it
the snuggles are worth it man yeah
depending on the cat
like look like we don't
ours isn't in Crazy radius away from us
okay and you can't you don't notice it
when you come into our apartment you
don't notice it when you're in the room
that it's in we do a good job of keeping
it circulated but every once in a while
man you catch a [ __ ] heater from her
that is like it's not even it almost
makes dog poop smell good
that's how bad that's how bad cats are
living with it that's great and I
understand it's a real good job but it's
like ammonia it's it did it's not listen
you catch one respect yeah it'll wake
you up in the middle of the night like
what the [ __ ] that's yeah no it's I've
seen some baking soda on that I respect
I'll believe you that you do a real good
job taking care of you've been on the
record you've been in my apartment I've
never smelled cat I I can't recall your
honor but everybody slouches a little
bit this is also coming from a guy who
had to chemically peel his floor when he
got his new dog yeah I know you talk
shits in the dishwasher not anymore not
anymore
your animal has to do it
inside yeah she does it in her little
thing yeah that's in Europe that's too
much it's too much you think so but I
know listen the technology and kitty
litter over the last 30 years is
tremendous they're halfway to
disintegrated immediately because if it
doesn't I'm out
or something
then I'm listening but you're nuts but
never on carpet it's on hardwood and
then they have a little she has a little
a little mat right in front of it and
it's always like there's always little
Pebble like there's a litter always gets
out of the thing from their feet or
whatever we don't have that we step on
it if we give her people food which we
rarely ever do but if there's like a
little piece of salmon or something like
that we'll give it to her
um that usually [ __ ] her up a little
bit and she'll drag her butt a little
bit on the on the hardwood you see a
little streak I mean I do love doll I
love Adam but they are you know you're
just essentially living with
somebody who shits in your apartment in
a litter box it gets covered up by the
litter I [ __ ] in my apartment too dog
yeah you flush it and it goes right down
I don't all the time
but you clean the litter box every day
come on what are we doing here you don't
even clean your I've I've shared
bathrooms with you there's your pay is
all over there I don't handle it what I
don't handle the litter box situation
okay yeah she does a good job with it
okay yeah now the urine thing the P
thing yeah I would all just argue to say
that the guy hold on the the species in
the house that knows how to use the
toilet doesn't do a good job with it I
doubt the cat's doing a great job with
it that's all I'm saying
I I learned from you man I thought we
all peed on the floor and yes I did rule
in my hardwood floors and I will be
losing my security
[Laughter]
I don't know what business of it is
yours
okay let's talk about DraftKings baby oh
baby the king of the draft let's talk
about letting it ride you know what I'm
saying I'm an action Jackson when it
comes to gambling I'll tell you this
you's may know that the playoff
picture's pretty much mapped out uh-huh
Road here to Super Bowl 57. why not get
in a little action go Barry you know
what I mean spice it up a little bit
yeah that AFC divisional game
see what you're made of uh it's a
Thursday night game you get paid
tomorrow
haven't watched one Chiefs game all year
you're laying the mortgage payment
[ __ ] house let's go it's a good time
here's a cool thing that they got going
on over there what's that you do a five
dollar bet okay they give you 200 worth
of free bets okay I like that that ain't
bad instantly you're playing with house
money what are we doing listen I'm
betting everything on the birds yeah it
laid it all on the birds this year plus
they got all new and existing all new
and existing customers get a no sweat
bet each day of the Wild Card around
this week just place any NFL bet of your
choice and if it loses you'll get to
you'll get a free BET back up to ten
dollars action's so good why bet the NFL
playoffs anywhere else baby I'll tell
you what I ain't I'm not going to some
Joe Shmoe at the at the at the Elks
Lodge to lay my bets I'm going through a
guaranteed I know somebody who I know
has got the cash and that's DraftKings
baby download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now and use promo code ayg new
customers get 5 dollars get new
customers can bet five dollars on the
NFL and get 200 in free bets instantly
only at DraftKings sports book with
promo code ayg minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see the
show notes for details Kip how about
them Factory meals
love that factor shout out to the turkey
chili nothing like coming home and
finding a box of factors just sitting
there now the way they design it is to
eat right exercise and move forward sure
you get two three of those in here yeah
it'll be in two or three of them like
the big man likes to do
I gotta be honest with you no joking
around signed up this morning yeah I'm
back on it baby 2023 is the year of the
kip that's what we're doing I'm getting
back I'm getting back down to fight and
wait gang Two Fat Guys on the show
fantastic fresh never frozen meals it's
not like uh the other way you got to
make the [ __ ] yourself it's all done
it's done you throw it in the microwave
throw it in a little pan with a little
bit of olive oil or something two
minutes in a microwave a couple of holes
yeah and it's good clean stuff man it's
good time it's fantastic I think I've if
you know I've been a I've been I've been
a factor guy for a long time big
proponent T-Bone was on it for a long
time it was 28 pounds or something there
you go uh with calorie smart and keto
options Factor meals are perfectly
portioned to keep you on track with your
goals they now offer 34 meals per week
and over three dozen add-on options
had to go I did it this morning had to
go factor75.com garbage six they don't
even need to look because I know it use
code garbage60 to get 60 off your first
box that's code garbage60
at
go.factor75.com garbage60 to get 60 off
your first box do it he's not pooping in
the house anymore ah never come on I
forgot I thought he I thought he peed in
the car pooped in the car or something
like that now he threw up a couple but
he was still like a real puppy also the
car is in the house
yeah well I mean that was like eight
months ago or something okay no he
hasn't he hasn't he hasn't gone the
bathroom in the house and gee like I I
genuinely have no idea when okay he
knows better okay he's gonna rough him
up yeah get him in a headlock all right
this one's for Mark Sullivan ever stick
a Bernie in your nose and take a
backwards drag
that's a good time yikes
I always thought it was real creepy
that guy parties dude yeah shout out to
mark That's a guy who gets fired at the
Holiday party for his job oh yeah I
thought it was always
I thought it was always weird and I
never really I don't do it when when
people have to come out of their nose my
dad was big Jesus that's when you're
smoking uh-huh that's an issue man just
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] like Raging Bull
coming out you know what I mean I burned
a different kind of Burn yeah and that's
an accent imagine taking that on the web
are you [ __ ] Lucifer I mean that's
some [ __ ] Hellboy would do that's a
stunt right that's gotta be it no dude I
remember this no I'm saying the nose but
of course of course but seeing those old
schoolers back in the day he's like
fixing something in the car once hanging
out yeah blast that thing out it's
rolling gold dude God damn the original
Vapors like a local original blowing
clouds dude like the Polar Express
coming down the tracks yeah now I'm a
standard uh standard smoke exhale kind
of guy however that was the French the
French oh the French in hell would be
out a little bit through the nose I've
done that a little bit back to back
jerked off like that now that's the
overhand what are we doing aka the
turncoat
love resistance
leave it off that's where when you're
interrogating yourself
hey you like that huh you like that
that's just before the phone book comes
out
then pick a letter what start
waterboarding
oh that's a good time the French Inhale
right you would let some out and then
suck that through your nose correct out
the mouth through the nose yeah
if a hot chick does that that's one
thing yeah you do it you know
look at bison I have an asthma attack
right away
uh uh yeah that's a tough look but
that's just a fun time what he's talking
about yeah that's just being silly
that's a party goof yeah you're wearing
a tuxedo t-shirt doing that you're
killing yeah you ever see the tough guy
shot what's that it's where you tail no
it's a shot of tequila where you snort
the salt do the tequila and then squirt
the lime in your eye oh God who are you
hanging out with what are the rest of
the Pirates doing yeah that's crazy I
wonder why you quit drinking you know
you don't gotta you can just have a
cocktail like a gentleman you're not
gonna do that you never chug a beer then
punch yourself in the dick
no I'm good dude you know the carpenter
you stick a nail in your thigh do a shot
then you call out of work eat a ham
sandwich
Jesus
what do you call it the tough guy the
tough guy shot
hey need a new friend shot that's what
that is
Gentlemen please leave
that's a shot it is
you're trying to get your picture up at
a bar for the wrong reasons
father butt heavy a shot of Jameson some
broken glass please
[Laughter]
do the Shutter Island shot real quick is
there anyone in the back of the stuff on
my balls
I'm trying to get [ __ ] up is it still
happy hour
can someone put a stick out on my eye
all right this one's from Chowder stash
first time long time ever have to pull
over on the expressway because you think
that Bernie launched out the window got
stuck in the back window and is burning
a hole in the fine leather of your 2003
Mercury Sable man talk about the panic
button when that [ __ ] happens that's
happened to me a couple of times before
I've got it in the crotch where it did
that and it goes down in the crotch and
you because when it goes down in the
crotch you inherit the movement to go
get it pushes it further down then you
get up thinking that's a good idea and
it rolls down the whole time you're
pressing on the gas because you need
leverage to get your ass off to see dude
talk about Houston we got a problem
each decision leads to an exponentially
worse result dude plus you're in panic
mode you're all over the road you don't
know you're you're incapable of anything
yeah you shove it further down then you
go to stand up you go faster and then it
rolls back under you God forbid you
start feeling that heat on your
testicles
I remember sitting next to my dad and
all of a sudden that went out
I'd be reaching around I'd be his eyes
on I'd be his eyes on the ground
oh dude I pull over immediately [ __ ]
deal with that that's tough dude uh we
got I remember the first time we got
called my brother my buddy got his
license we went out drove in his mom's
caught like his mom's like had like a
Chevy Envoy or something
we took that out everybody's [ __ ]
smoking I guess he was just at this
point we dropped everybody off but it
was just me and him
Eddie flicked it and it went in the back
and then in the back seat and he was
like I think so and I remember being
like nah you're good it's fine what are
the chances of that type thing sure as
[ __ ] dude it burned a hole like this big
on the floor
his mom's like dude shuts up [ __ ] are
spoken to my car did she smoke yeah I'm
like what are we doing here tuts could
have been you nah but that was back in
the in the dude that like dude we used
to smoke at my mom's house like I'd have
like 50 people over and everybody would
just smoke cigs and she'd like down the
shore I would just like open the windows
wouldn't notice when they got back I
think our sense of smell God
more I would say years got worse no I
would I would say that
you notice it now way more than you did
like exactly what you're saying like
you're not everybody's back in the day
everybody was smoking everywhere
restaurants and [ __ ] everybody about
things
yeah I guess you can't even smoke in the
middle of a goddamn empty field you
gotta be 5 000 feet away from somebody I
mean if you were in a restaurant
somebody was smoking crazy that's great
you would you would you would what the
[ __ ] I don't like smoking indoors unless
I'm real [ __ ] up and I'm the only guy
doing it and it's illegal I remember
what I remember when it's time for Kimmy
to make a power play unless I'm about to
close on a deal
of me getting thrown out of a bar
your move
picking yourself off the sidewalk and
that's how you don't pay for the bill
now who's got a light broken cigarette
um I remember I remember waiting tables
and smoking like being at the bar
somebody would come in sit down YouTube
when this waiter comes back after a Sig
break you're like why don't you just
give me my garlic bread in an ash dress
especially now in the winter get out of
here with that
oh man it's tough you feel the cold on
them
shit's no bueno no and there you always
the Sig break the quick Sig break is
always the worst because you're just
steamrolling it dude you're not even
getting any Oxygen in there that's all
creamy Rich smoke that used to drive me
crazy back in the day when somebody
would ask me for a a pull off your smoke
and they'd [ __ ] steamroll it to get a
handy a torpedo back to Cherry on that
thing they get along you're like what
the [ __ ] switched over to nuclear not to
mention the [ __ ] the typer speed the
tip of it's soaking wet you're like what
and it's pinched down it's like Jesus
Christ yeah if I could raw dog my heater
he gave it back to me or deed my age my
wedding night for Christ's sakes what
the [ __ ] wrong with you yeah that's
tough
um this one's from Kevin 10 shareholder
is it garbage to ask for a Rogaine
subscription as a birthday gift hey
fellow bald Kevin the bald Kevin I
respect it my man what's the what's the
coinage on something like that ah don't
they sell it in CVS now you go in there
and get it oh oh
license when you get that no it's not
spray paint
I figure this way the government want to
keep an eye on because the kids aren't
getting high on it
I just thinking the government want to
keep an eye on you bulldoze I may even
make sure we're not all we're going to
make sure we're not all banding together
you gotta start every neighborhood you
move to you got to go around tell
everybody you can't be I'm bald I'm your
new neighbor
get the hell off my lawn
get the hell off my toupee no I don't
think so subscriptions are nice yeah no
it's good it's probably cheap now it's
probably like maybe 15 bucks a month or
something like that 28.99 a month with
who Rogan yeah but no that's you go uh
generic their patent came out it seems
like it's working good
oh Toby's fired
hey you might want to switch over to the
real deal
I am on Rogaine
I got a real stuff RC Cola over here
I can't get a glass of Rogaine we got
Pro or whatever but yours is spelled
r-o-u-g-h-k
[Laughter]
kids using ketchup
cats up I'm cutting me out of this whole
thing man
I'm having a good time though
um all right let's see here uh uh this
one's from Bridget new to patreon ever
had a swing set made from scrap Lumber
instead of your parents getting one from
a store
I mean your dad would have to be pretty
[ __ ] handy to put something like that
together but you're back there playing
on broken down pallets yeah that's tough
uh there's you're getting splinters on
that thing for sure dude swinging on an
old toilet seat
man that's a tough look that's bad you'd
have to be able to do it good or
probably not that's the thing too yeah
scrap Lumber is a tough one unless it's
again done very well and I respect it
but
chances are you're probably cutting a
couple of Corners you got to be real
good with your angles and stuff like
that yeah which like if you're half in
the like you gotta you know you got you
gotta Jimmy that stuff a lot you know
that's like you don't all have this you
know it's like a two by four or four by
six but anything wood as far as I'm
concerned anything wood is better than
the metal that I had when I was a kid we
had the real cheap aluminum ones back
out of the ground and then when I got a
little bit older I started seeing uh
kids with parents had a little money
they'd get those [ __ ] those nice
wooden ones that have like the the
yellow and blue and red top yeah they
have like a little Pirate's nest and the
steering wheel or some monkey bars and
stuff like that to slide ours was
straight up two swings and a lot of
times they had like the sea salt like
the Dual Cedar the good ones no the bad
ones yeah the bad one the bad like you
had one dual Cedar he had two regular
swings and I think some monkey bars and
that was it there was no slot maybe
there was a slot metal slide maybe but
no slide with a little house on top you
were right up and over
and it was rough going down I remember
catching the inside of my thighs no on
that on the hinge on the double thing oh
I thought you meant on the slide itself
on a hot slide
yeah
we had we had the our swing set was just
the pipes that are like the A-frame with
the one going across yeah but it wasn't
stuck into the ground so it would always
pop out so yeah you'd go back and the
whole front end would come up
that's crazy yeah that was just like
nobody even said you didn't even tell
your parents that would happen it just
happened that was one good thing about
my dad he always over concreted Ah
that's a good bag of Quikrete oh man
four or five bags of quickread for one
of those things like when I was home I
just noticed that we have the uh we used
to have a basketball pole it's in your
cribs that we did I don't know if it
ever made it but I remember seeing it I
brought Toby over I go he still has the
you still got to they just cut it they
didn't dig it out yeah you got the roots
still in there it's like a bad tooth
yeah you would need like the Army Corps
of Engineers to get that thing out of
the ground there's probably probably
goes down to like seven sub levels it's
crazy
pull it out lava starts coming up
um we I I think I don't know if I ever
told you we I tried to get one my dad I
wanted that that like that dark wood
treated with the yellow the blue red and
we went to this place up off street road
somewhere if I remember correctly we put
down a two hundred dollar down payment
and I'm like I'm [ __ ] getting this
this is great this is I'm gonna be the
cool guy on the [ __ ] block
and then a week later my dad never heard
from him we drove by a weekly you know a
week later my dad called Nothing another
week whatever we finally drove by they
had gone out of business took the 200
deposit and skipped town adiosity yeah
we were [ __ ] I was so perfect let's
go somewhere else that was it man I
wasn't he wasn't trusting another guy
when the swing set people are playing
Hardball you got to be a cold-hearted
son of a [ __ ] steal a kid's good time
yeah I mean getting get into like uh you
know a scam Center or something like
that yeah
something you're wiping the smile off my
face buddy that was my goddamn Christmas
present it was either that or braces
you even get those second hand they're
still good they go they stay last they
go around a little bit yeah things are
all right yeah we never had anything we
had we built a tree house in the back
that my neighbor came and yelled at me
for because it was technically on his
property I can't [ __ ] you're using
his power
Ellen I came and shut down that job here
they see you there
yeah beware a dog sign up there keep him
out yeah I got jammed up but he never
had the did you guys ever have a zip
line as a kid Nah if any with the skin
he did it's so funny you mentioned that
I would have never have thought about
that one we tried to make a couple to no
avail we we made some that ripped really
yeah we had a tree fort we tied a rope
from the top of the tree fort just to a
tree and then we had almost it was like
a dog leash that we doubled up and then
you'd clip it on with a couple of freaks
what do you eat what were you we never
had the material what will you use in
regular uh uh what's it called rope no
laundry line rope it was like climbing
rope really yeah see we just had that
[ __ ] that where she hanged the hung the
sheets we had a real cool dad in the
neighborhood yeah you need somebody like
that well I remember you could buy the
Vinnie with the skinny had one where
you'd have to climb up the back of his
shed get past the wasp nest man Jesus
Christ those things were coming out of
the cinder blocks yikes had it climb to
the top we were raccoons coming at you
we were sick or seven maybe crazy climb
up the back of the shed no ladder like
you'd stand on like a wheelbarrow then
like a set of bricks and then like you
get up there my fat ass pulling myself
up you get up there then you're on his
shed and you would just [ __ ] he had a
proper one yeah my cousin my cousin has
a problem
remember the first time I didn't realize
how much upper body
I went I went down like a sack of
potatoes when I did that kind of stuff
when I was a kid it made me realize that
if I was ever hanging off of a
helicopter I would never make it yeah
I'd be like Robert De Niro in uh the
deer hunter I'd fall down gang let's
talk about ladder look at that you like
screwing over your family sure we all do
we're all dirt bags when it comes to
term life insurance you don't want to
leave them holding the bag as they say
yeah putting the quarters over your eyes
as you cross the river to the boat man
one final screw job to the wife and kids
don't do it take care of your financial
affairs even if you ain't got a lot of
money you can still get up to three
million yeah a little something no
needles no doctors no nothing do it all
online sign up get yourself covered baby
yeah ladder with ladder made Forbes best
life insurance list in 2021 and it's
really easy to see why no hidden fees
cancel anytime get a full refund if you
cancel on a first charity days life
insurance gets more expensive as you age
so why so the time time to buy is now
n-o-w I'm a Buy Low Die High baby that's
what I always say I I go out I'll smoke
that uh go to that don't be doing that
don't don't do that go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder l-a-d-d-r
life.com garbage letterlife.com garbage
don't get high
now back to the show
that was a big thing when I when I I've
put all the way back on over the most of
it but when I first lost the weight I
wanted when I was like I'm in shape I'm
like I just wanted like apocalypse style
skills like I wanted to be able to do
one pull-up I've made myself always be
able to do one player in case I was ever
hanging from a helicopter or a ledge a
cliff we're gonna be able to get myself
back up that and I can run a mile flat
out without stopping outrun your fat ass
don't let the zombies or the wolves get
you I'm out that learned how to use a
crossbow yeah always keep a blade on you
too but that was my big thing of like I
just want to be able to do these because
I could never do them as a kid so I'm
like I just wanted to be able to do
these things who would of the three of
us who would survive the longest in an
apocalypse I would for sure
what are we talking about what kind of
Apocalypse attack of the Cheez-Its
about to paint my masterpiece
what do you mean
okay let's let's say for nuke went off
in the in the distant area and it shut
the grid down Mad Max we'll say Mad Max
post nuclear fallout
oh this is the bonus we're doing this
this week by the way okay yeah yeah
great love it what how to survive an
apocalypse I mean in my heart nobody's
surviving
not that long
I think you grossly underestimate my
outdoorsiness do you have a do you have
a bug out bag
yes included with my albuterol inhaler
and my nebulizer in case I need a
treatment in case there's cats at this
apocalypse
what's the dander sick
yeah I mean I can't go three days
without my heartburn medicine
oh and you can also feed a whole village
so yeah either way I'll be miserable
nobody's eating each other that's that I
don't think that's a viable solution
plenty of deer running around we already
talked about right fellas right no one
wants it don't seen each other I
wouldn't be any good I'll start throwing
seasoning on you
Salt Bay yet
[Laughter]
Gold Leaf around me
oh buddy this is the fattest guy in the
village after the apocalypse going I
mean come on come on We're not gonna eat
people or a lot of studies show as high
in cholesterol as I am what are you
crazy I'm gonna be like DeNiro and David
was mean I'd be like De Niro at the end
the casino now keep going further down
further down further down whack you off
real quick thanks to you know I'm in an
air fryer
no thanks
um I mean I have my depending on the
situation I have my my out and my route
and where I would go and what I would do
and stuff like that who's gonna tie your
shoes for you
you better hope those zombies are nice
okay
hey buddy can you find my shoe horn for
me give me a five minute Head Start no
faces all right you do have the biggest
shoehorn I've ever seen a man own no I
have a bigger one at my mom's
well you're not allowed to have it in
New York
can't bring it through the tunnel it's
illegal not a paper sport it was my
grandfather so you know it just kind of
stayed in the family oh blue that's a
long gun you guys it's made of iron or
something too because the other ones
they all Bend this one man made out of
railroad spike dude I'm telling you
you're gonna need that when the zombies
come dude you just start putting that
through their brains that'd be pretty
sweet if that was my weapon my shoehorn
you can jack the house up with this
thing I'm telling you it's legit yeah
the one that you guys saw at the airport
remember I was worried about bringing on
the plane which I can't believe they let
me
tear through that thing like John Wick
with that thing in my hand
you could bring a bazooka on the plane
and you're not getting anything done all
right yeah your weapons on a plane or a
shoehorn and a seat belt extender
that's pretty good I'm very specific
tennis Hills now someone help me out of
my seat please
there's a federal government's not said
I'm too fat to fly
at my overhead bag please I would have
saved everyone on that plane if they had
sat me in an aisle
can't get out
right in the middle of this movie though
[Laughter]
they're pretty sweet oh man the shoehorn
in this and this it's perfect for all
right
we'll talk about it more on the old
patreon he's a shield too
um that's a great one that's a great
theme that we've never done that's fun
it's all right how to survive an
apocalypse I like it
uh uh all right let's see here uh this
is from Dave from Minnesota new home he
never had one red has anyone convinced
you a bed sheet would work as a
parachute and got you to jump off of
something umbrella really yeah doesn't
work
[Laughter]
doesn't work no it's tough I I remember
doing I remember being that age and
doing that math as a kid of like
well it should be able to smoke off my
because we could get onto the one part
of my roof through my sisters like we
get on the roof of my garage for my
sisters it's another thing if you had
the strength like if I had the strength
to hold on to the umbrella and it stayed
structurally intact which the way that I
was at the time when I did it it should
have no
it doesn't have enough time to slow you
down you don't think an umbrella no this
was this was second floor
um no so no I would argue yeah no you're
moving too I don't know you're even too
quick too fast for uh anything to slow
you down let's see it's got to slow you
down in you know 12 feet that's
impossible
uh Eric roner R.I.P uh the skydiver with
the Nitro Circus Travis Pastrana's crew
he just he did an umbrella Skydive an
umbrella but it was like custom sure it
was like a parachute oh yeah did he jump
out of a plane or out of his uh bathroom
window uh out of a plane oh okay did he
hang on to it well yeah probably for a
little while to his hand I think he made
it all the way down on it just holding
it I believe so yes get the [ __ ] out of
here you would have to have so much hand
strength to hold on to yourself I don't
know that's wild I remember and I'm sure
he had another parachute on him just in
case oh of course sure
he's not a real skydiver like you folks
he doesn't live on the edge this guy's a
real [ __ ] composer it worked for a
little bit and then you have one of your
mom's five dollar umbrellas and jump off
the back deck I'll show you what it's
like
a real one
yeah you're too broken you want two
broken feet a sheet not because I could
never figure out how to get it where it
would work
yeah none of it works you need more
space it's it's the space yeah that you
would need but I think and let alone a
better parachute system my brother or
one of my one of my older cousins told
me that uh if I put it if I if I did it
like a cape I could I could yeah that's
how that's how everybody gets a that's
how everybody gets jammed up that's how
I got I was playing Superman off my
couch and yeah the header onto the
coffee table they just pushed me down
the steps yeah they told me that I'd be
able to fly I could fly down the steps
they just pushed me down and laughed at
me
still got these kids numbers they sound
all right
as I can hang with
shout out to Flo and the duck and the
boys uh that's good stuff
all right uh this is from Jameson uh
ever been in a pinch and had to use
chapstick on your hands because you
didn't have lotion available God damn
smelling like strawberries but my shit's
all [ __ ] up here
I use it on my face it's really
moisturize it's just good moisturizer at
the end of the day huh not really it
seals it in yeah that's good it seals in
the moisture oh one more to you once
again what do you want a sear in a steak
you know what I mean
no I'm just saying if I'm jammed up or
whatever and I'm like I have like
visibly like in the winter if it's like
visibly dry don't use CarMax I don't
[ __ ] uh no you do uh you're doing a
love scene
falling your eyes out you do uh yeah
just it just takes it takes the edge off
you know what I mean just moisturizes in
the in the moment I feel like we might
have talked about this recently
somewhere it could have been in private
but we were talking about ChapStick and
I said the worst was Blistex when your
lips were real jammed up I remember
Blistex being all right mate it was real
it was more liquidy it wasn't the
squeeze tube yes it would come out like
a it would come out like a dog was
pooping yes yeah but it was loose it
wasn't to protect your lips it was to it
was to [ __ ] burn the [ __ ] out of it
when they were chapped it was that was
the medical reason for it well it was to
treat it it was just when you had some
medicated so when you had severe chapped
lips and you could rub you'd rub it in
and you would rub off the extra pieces
of dead skin so it would start to heal
that's how we did it [ __ ] brutal yeah
burned the [ __ ] out of you that in the
Halls cough drop when you were a kid
might as well be bear spray it [ __ ]
sucked I love the good holes I got in
the Halls early as a kid yeah my sister
was taking them she was like six she was
like 13 or 14. I was probably about
seven got my hands on one of them never
looked back opened you up real quick
talk about mainlining dude that and then
a [ __ ] Hi-C juice box
it's like been chocolate chip ice cream
yeah it's that little bastard
no I didn't [ __ ] with him I was a
luden's kid I I was just somewhere I was
down at home and the kids were all
running around had ludens talking about
looting now where does luden's at yeah
why don't you show Uncle Kevin you know
it wasn't bad
we kicked it off with the original
Cherry then they dropped a lemon
but then they got into the it was like
honey something I think it was Honey
Lemon man those things were delish have
that for lunch that a cup of soup you're
all right get my head on straight
uh uh all right let's see here this is
from Brian is a garbage to bring your
leftover pizza to work for lunch in the
Box it was delivered in
man what's this office space talk about
not giving a [ __ ] that's bad I like it
you gotta rearrange stuff in the fridge
to get it in there yeah for two slices
tin foil a bag or something I tell you
what this kid sounds all right though by
his own rules real [ __ ] Cowboy that's
pretty good
oh that's a dude that takes if they have
food at the office for something like
bagels or sandwiches take stuff home
he's taking that [ __ ] home with him yeah
I never liked doing that I'm like
carrying stuff I'm just a huge Hoagie
tray guy the idea of it it's
intoxicating just having all those
Hoagies
you mean I can have all these nuts I get
I Get Crazy around a hoagie tray more so
than anything really that's your
Kryptonite 100
I get crazy around that and for some
reason I have this we I didn't do it I
didn't I didn't do it partially because
the expiration date was real close but
around the holidays we always had those
pinwheels so they're like wraps to get
them at Costco they're wraps and they
have like turkey and like cream cheese
and a tomato or something in there
tomato and cranberry for some reason
yeah I'm not a fan of that [ __ ] dude I
really never liked them anyway but I
would always find myself eating 100 of
them and like with like I loved them
sure it was weird
um
I almost I'm infatuated with them
because I almost got it when we were at
Costco last but the expiration date was
like the day before and they get real
wet around the side when they start to
go oh they sweat yeah it's a tough luck
how far after the expiration date will
you fellas push it I won't even even if
it's like a day before I I won't [ __ ]
with it if it's even close I'm out milk
a few days if it doesn't smell you can
tell if it depends how jammed up I am if
it's sell buyer used by sell by I'll
give you a two three days I'll do it
I'll do two three days yeah yeah but
usually I don't I don't get I don't [ __ ]
with it at all plus I'd always hate
growing up as a kid you get the lunch
meat the date on that would be that it
would it would be in the sell by
or used by box like all you know how
like the like on the sticker
Supermarket yeah and you get like sliced
meat the sticker you have the guys doing
that that gets printed out fresh I know
let me finish it says that date where
the the number it was the date it was
cut yeah but it would always fall on the
used by or like sell by date
you see what I'm saying no there was a
template on those stickers yes size
description wait use by date and it was
used by date yes but it was the date on
what you got it sliced
really yeah yeah yeah now ours was
always like a week away
it would compute it no ours was always
the day of why would it say used by the
day of that's that's why I brought it up
so you had no idea what the hell was
going on no well you know what day you
bought it
I think ours said used by like September
7th they they put they they marked it
out I mean they are still doing I looked
at it the other day really yeah yeah
which makes me think that's like a
apology
still
it's Jesus Christ
that's how I think I'm like Mom what the
[ __ ] we got a whole pan of the turkey
and he didn't even [ __ ] touch it she
goes I bought that yesterday I said I
thought it wasn't used
this is what I'm saying man
I don't know about that I'm telling you
dude I posted about it but I found a
bottle of hot sauce at my parents place
that went out in 2018. I mean that's
just crazy dude because that stuff's
like
that's what you need an apocalypse I
don't last we pulled a thing of red wine
vinegar out of the back of the cabinet
when we were moving that wine
Chianti
now dude it had that thing in there that
uh that's the [ __ ] dude had the worm
in there yikes it's I think it's I think
it's what they kind of used to make
kombucha some kind of bacteria pod forms
or something oh yeah I think was looking
at me I'm [ __ ] that chicken that's
like a thing of jello that thing got
thrown right the [ __ ] out yeah but no
and oh I don't know this about the
lunchroom I'm telling you man I'm
telling you the the sticker has used by
on it because you want to get me fired
up but it's the day they slice it's that
day they buy it that's because I kept
going yeah you're buying you you're
buying old [ __ ] that's what are you
doing here I guess that makes sense
because how would they have the
technology back then to forecast
forecast whatever on that one machine
then
what it was a computer kind of dude
that's a scale
but the scale had computer parts inside
of it it was digital so maybe it knew it
did it I'm telling you I feel real bad
dude just over the holidays
I was home like four or five times every
time what are you doing get rid of this
is bad I did it that's good then I come
home the next time because you want to
piss me off let me open up that Deli
drawer and think I got a a nice half a
pound of [ __ ] turkey in there and
then think that I can't have it yeah
it's a good thing she has a little
Cracker Barrel cheeses in there
keep your head on straight a couple of
pepperoni I rolled the dice of some old
pork roll but I figured that's Gotta Be
You know it was it was a little foggy
but I said you know what if I get it hot
enough the eyes were a little glassy
like fresh fish oh man
you can't trust anything at those houses
anymore
I caught her with chicken hot dogs the
other day
chicken hot dogs and the way I noticed
that something was up is they weren't
all the same color one was a little
darker
holiday pack
somebody passed me a green diesel one
was one was a little bit discolored like
it was like you know like micro made or
something like that I don't know what
the [ __ ] is this particular give me that
[ __ ] out yeah
tires on it she's keeping the bread in
the fridge too because if they don't eat
it quick enough that's weird though man
you don't know you don't know what
you're dealing with I know you really
don't you don't know what you're dealing
I made two pork roll egg and cheeses on
hamburger buns that I think were from
July 4th
this was yesterday
I was dude they they didn't have mold on
them but they were you know it smelled
like fireworks yeah these things these
things were pre-labor day I know that
smelled like fireworks you find a
ladybug in there you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah we had a summer saving sticker
on them
um
she uh [ __ ] what was I gonna say well
with the eggs the eggs now she gets them
from some lady no I don't trust that
that she and the ladies tell her that
they're good for three months they're
regular out of the chicken eggs so she
now she's marking the date on them
yeah it's like Jurassic world there
are good picks it up that's it I tried
to make breakfast yet I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this Patty a Dino Pops up oh you
Beaty Wong what are you doing here
man that guy's a pure scientist he's
working shout out to him that's funny
um crazy
yeah but correct me if I'm wrong I would
love to know like hold on I get to the
house now it's like is there some
pretzels or something
I'm not going into anything I know it's
tough Wild's top plus half the shit's
the dog you start matching down on some
green beans and a little bit of ground
beef and next thing we shot it for the
dog your coat's shiny
Wild
dude she's not wrong fresh eggs like
from straight from the chicken three
months in the refrigerator yeah dude
that's big ass woman's probably buying
them at a goddamn Wawa and pawning them
off as their own yeah are you nuts I
wouldn't nothing lasts for three months
that's crazy
I don't care yeah the lady that is
chicken [ __ ] on her shoulder selling
that to mine feathers yeah you know
she's got like she's old and gray as a
short haircut now yeah it's time now
they're fine we do it all the time
nothing's wrong with me
her eyes are rolling back here [ __ ]
dead baby in the car
get out of here
yeah give that [ __ ] a week the eggs at
my mom she jams me up because she takes
them out and puts them in the holder
like she's got like so you don't hear
I'm like I I'm like I've just had
because I'm real I'm real OCD anal about
that [ __ ] I don't like rolling the dice
but there you just gotta do it dude half
the time I'm cracking it I think I just
expected a feather to pop out or
something a beak [ __ ] are you doing
Ozzy I'm sleeping in here [ __ ] yeah
you got you just never and you never
know never know oh dude like I told her
she got a load up on a frozen get Frozen
stuff I know what I'm dealing with when
I come down for you selfish
not her uh you could really eat whatever
you want just make sure you have Frozen
[ __ ] appetite the only thing that's
good now she eats out a lot so you get
home me too little little chicken
cacciatore somewhere in the back of that
thing yeah not bad shrimp scampi that's
what Denny's Denny's likes a Scamp ooh
shrimp scampi ice cold the next day no
problem with it it's all right I'll even
do the linguine cold
um all right let's see here speaking of
this is from Kyle is it garbage to use
you're enclosed patio space in the
winter as a refrigerator since there is
no garage fridge note this winter has
been spotty with the daily temperatures
some of the fritz that's talking about
50 today in New York man those eggs
ain't holding I don't care if you're
Patty if you're Denise those are bad
eggs you're gonna cook that tilapia
tonight
buddy what are the specials tonight
buddy you're losing shelf space whip
something up with that yeah I don't know
what to tell you on that if you live in
like Wisconsin or something you get a
deep freeze yeah I could see that but I
don't even like uh Patty puts the water
bottles out there in the sun room she
leaves them out there it's cold in the
winter it's good but the sunlight's
going directly into them you pick one of
those things up they're glowing yeah
it's weird
yeah dude I'm like what are you doing
yeah that's tough I mean we do what we
do it with the you know we did on
Christmas we had that it was freezing at
Christmas I went and got beers just kept
them right outside oh my cousins
ice cold IPA screamer not a drop of ice
just sitting out there do we just have
them in the 12 packs or the Sixers
whatever you go grab another one yeah
that was all right that's I get that
that was sodas is okay if it's in the
garage and it's not you know the sun's
not baking on it whatever but yeah you
gotta
you can't be leaving like raw meat and
[ __ ] out there no it ain't that cold no
you can't do that [ __ ] in Alaska there's
a guy on Instagram that does that he has
all this [ __ ] out signing is that and he
cuts it up and eats like slivers of
frozen fish
what looks pretty good in Alaska yeah
it's wonky really yeah when you think of
Alaska do you immediately picture a guy
in a canoe with an eagle flying overhead
no I think drunk guy covered in snow
that's what I I go to like I go to like
Anchorage type stuff
the Hukilau or whatever
or choo choo Charlie's there's a famous
uh Comedy Club up there oh yeah yeah
Charlie's or something
however you gotta take your underwear
off to her foot something wild Cannon
was just up there
could you say a drug guy with what I
covered in snow or something and a snow
bank chill coot Charlie's Charlie's yeah
we should go I'm down yeah hell yeah
I don't know those planes that get up
there
oh yeah [ __ ] that I could you get him
you see the guys spin the propeller
before you back out look at that
unless I got a movie screen on the back
of the seat I mind going I know that's
it I don't like that he's saying stuff
like oh he's gotta ease her in
spend a month in the wilderness with him
no thank you especially if he doesn't
have any gin left
starts losing it you can't be a
passenger in a plane that has a nickname
like old Lucy's never done me wrong
banging on the
hold until my goal I don't want to be in
anything that would have to stop for gas
either
well we gotta fly by acreage and pick up
some fuel what the [ __ ] yeah what are we
doing um we've got to wrap her up here
gang ah what a fun one yep it was a
hootenai
gang tickets are still available for our
show in Alaska
foreign
to get in
um one salmon with the promo code
uh tickets are still available at
Gramercy Theater February 3rd seven
o'clock that's going they're a lot
that's under a hundo okay yeah yeah yeah
that could be gone [ __ ] me I was trying
to do a little bit I know I'm just
letting them know there's urgency out
there get cooking get them going baby
game we love you we'll see you next week
peace